uh for the people who did listen to my
lightning talk yesterday
you are not going to answer this
question only those who did not listen
to me yesterday is supposed to
do this one
do you think i can talk for eight hours
straight without any breaks at all
about passwords and call that a brief
introduction to the topic raise your
hand if you think i can do that
people know me already okay
and for those who did listen to me
yesterday do you agree
yes
well yeah it's true i haven't done it
for real but i do think that i can talk
for eight hours
and still call that a very brief
introduction to this topic
so my name is per i did this joke
yesterday i'm not going to repeat it and
blah blah blah come on thinks i'm crazy
that's rather true
um and i'm 50 years old i have a
daughter aged 15 and she finds it very
embarrassing that her dad has a youtube
channel because i run my own conference
called passwords.com a non-profit where
we only talk about passwords and digital
authentication in all shapes forms and
sizes so you can find it there i have
tons of talks and it's not just me but
lots of other people that are really
good
at this topic that you can watch for
free as much as you want
i also talked yesterday about the value
of a password exemplified by this story
from associated associated press on
twitter
many years ago they tweeted out this
message saying that there had been an
explosion in the white house and
barack obama has been had been injured
that was fake news
it was only reported by ap and that
resulted in the dow jones stock index
dropping by
136.5 billion dollars
and this happened because a single
employee at the associated press fall
fellow victim to a phishing mail and
handed out the username and the password
for the twitter ap account
and they did not have 250 authentication
at the time on twitter so that was it
one username one password and suddenly
you have
a stroke market drop of 136.5 billion
dollars that's massive
and even crazier is
the hack was done by the syrian
electronic army
they said they were state
fans of president bashar al-assad or
maybe they were
state
sponsored hackers or
working for the government or maybe it
was something else we don't know
and we don't know if the syrian regime
or any other regime made any money out
of doing that hack
but that's again to me the value of a
single password a single user account in
the worst possible way
so i will start off with giving you a
couple of password recommendations i
made this by invitation from the
national cyber security alliance
in the us
it's the government and it's the big
tech companies that are all part of this
alliance
these recommendations were released for
the world password day in 2016. it's
true there's a world pastor day and in
2016 it was actually on may 4th may the
4th be with you so it's that easy to
remember so recommendation number one
from my side is
make your password a sentence
i don't know for english and u.s or
english-speaking people if the word
passphrase means anything to you but in
norwegian pastraza is not something it's
not a word that my mother understands
and most norwegians don't really
understand what you mean with pas fossa
but a passphrase
is something as simple as a sentence and
the funny thing is even today there's a
lot of people out there that don't know
they can use spaces in their passwords
because a password is a single word
to most people
but you can actually write a standard
norwegian
german
russian
japanese sentence
with spaces between the characters if
you like or between the words and use
that as your password in most systems
that's what i do that's what i want you
to tell your family and your friends and
colleagues yes you can use space in your
passwords
use
a normal
positive sentence about something that
you want to remember
number two
and i'm sorry to say this
but for every unique account you have
you really should have
a unique password
you're smiling yes i have more than 500
accounts and no i'm not a freaking
genius
so i use a password manager
and using a password manager goes into
trick number three write down your
passwords
now
many years ago
i went to visit my parents back home in
hergeson west coast of norway
and i told my mother that mom
you should write down your passwords she
doesn't have many of them she's uh
retired now and so is my dad
but i said to her you should write down
your passwords
and she just looked at me like no
i read it in the newspaper so you're not
supposed to do that and i said well
don't listen to newspapers listen to me
because i'm a global password security
expert or something like that
and she's like no
about i mean do you do a lot of talks i
know that but still i you know i trust
in newspapers for some reason
um and i said well
let's
you know let's be logical here mom uh do
you have any enemies
and she's what
do you have any enemies or anyone who
wants to kill you or steal your money
well nobody wants to kill me and steal
my money i
well there are bad people on the
internet i've read that in newspapers
well that's true
but if you write down your passwords and
put them in your kitchen drawer or well
in closet in your bedroom or something
like that
who would be interested in stealing that
piece of paper i have two younger
sisters
would i like to do that or would my
sisters do that well
if we did for the purpose of face
reaping your facebook account or for
stealing your money you know there will
be a family meeting i'm pretty sure of
that
and to the extent there is any money
left
i'm not getting them
if i hack your bank accounts
and i'm pretty sure the same applies for
my sisters as well
now
i may be wrong
but i don't think chinese or russian
intelligence is interested in going to
hogison
and find out where you live
and break into your house to steal that
paper
to steal your pension fund
and i i i don't know how large your
pension fund is but you have a normal
house and you have a normal car and
you've got that as well so i guess it's
you know it's
well it's worth the trip
to hoggerson but it's really not you
know there are other more interesting
targets
and then there's just one risk left and
that's dad
now if dad were to face rape your
facebook account that would just be
funny but it's it's not it's not a
problem
and that wouldn't steal your money
you're married
and i
suppose you will stay married as well
so write down your passwords
because that is so much smarter to do
than having people use the same shitty
password across all possible services
and just telling them that when you
write down your passwords of course
obviously number two use unique
passwords for each account and write it
down or use a password manager i would
never enforce a password manager on my
appearance because it's just too
technically advanced they don't know
they are running windows or ios or mac
os on the computer and they don't care
and not most importantly they are not
interested in learning about it either
it just wanted to work
and last but not least from the password
guy himself use two-fact authentication
everywhere you can
if
and especially if you think the account
is
worthy of any kind of protection
because passwords are not enough yes i
said it
and i also have good news for you
now this isn't really good news maybe
you've seen this before maybe you heard
this one before
but the next slide will bring you some
news that will give you so much joy
that i hope
and i believe that you you will applaud
it
maybe you'll whistle
maybe you will even stand up
and clap your hands and whistle and say
yes
love it
and if anybody wants to give me a hug
after the talk i'm you know i'm
available as well for that
are you ready for some great news
yes oh it's that early are you ready for
some great news
let's give it a try okay so mandatory
and frequent change of passwords are
stupid
[Applause]
yes excellent
because when you enforce this upon
people you are actually decreasing
security believe it or not i will get
back into that
it destroys the user experience and you
knew that from before and it's a waste
of valuable time
why should you change your password but
it hasn't been breached there's no
reason to think your account has been
breached nothing like that but you still
need to change it
there's absolutely no no point in doing
that
so a couple of years ago this is 2019
microsoft says
in a blog post
periodic password expiration is an
ancient and obsolete mitigation of very
low value and we don't believe it's
worthwhile for our baseline to enforce
any specific value so it's not just me
microsoft as well hurray for microsoft
i've been saying it since 2010 but
that's just me
but talking about passwords i have a
very important question
for you
and i need i need you to sort of think
about this question because this is
really really important
for the rest of my talk basically
and that question is do you need an
account for that
do i need to configure an account with
you in order to use your services
online
when you go to the grocery store to buy
milk do they ask you for a
user account for a password or pin in
order to
enter the store
anymore
north korea maybe but
when you leave you have to pay yes but
that is not like authenticating in any
way it's just paying which is fair
enough i do understand
yeah they want to get paid
but this question is incredibly
important because in a lot of cases
there's actually no need to create or
use an account at all i want to purchase
new shoes from your online store
give me you know show me the shoes
available let me pick the one that i
like
and to my shipping details and to my
credit card details which is probably
being entered into a third party payment
provider anyway
and tell me
excellent congratulations on your new
shoes they are now leaving
our store and they will be with you in
one two or three days
now
that's easy to do but why then
when i enter a new website and never
been to the one of the first things they
ask me is would you like to
log in would you like to create an
account or you have to log in before you
can use any services here at all
marketing purposes they want to spam me
but that is not really helping me it's
like would you like to have our
newsletter come in directly to your
mailbox like four times a day because
there are so many good offers for you
well i've never been here before
i just want to look at what kind of
shoes you have
do they do this in grocery stores like
when you enter the door you've never
been there before like hey
welcome let's show you around here's
milk there's chocolate here's biscuits
and here's
uh fruit and vegetables and here's the
meat and here's the fish and everything
no no no no no no you can't pick
anything yet we have to show you around
everything
and we need to send you physical letters
with offers in the mail they don't do
that
now changing the flow of this is
something i would get back to but i
think
that good user experience also provides
for good security
people and i know this from experience
i've been working with information
security since 1995 so i'm
really old
and i know from experience that if
security
is hard for users to use
they will do anything they can
to circumvent
or to break the security
and they will not tell security staff
because those guys are morons
anyway
so you have to make security that works
for people
so let's talk a little bit about the
onboarding and login process flow like
you know creating a new account because
i want to buy some new shoes
again i'm asking the question why do i
need an account with you
here's a
create a new account for and you as you
can see i have
incredibly delicate design skills in
powerpoint
so in a creating new account it's very
common to see that enter your email
because that will be your username and
then you have to create a password and
you have to enter the password to
confirm you can still find a lot of
websites that does the last part there
enter password one more time to confirm
first of all something simple you can do
you can use focus so that as soon as i
enter the web page the cursor is inside
the email box and i can't start typing i
don't have to use my mouse cursor to
place it in there and click and then
start writing
incredibly small
but very important usability step
you can also
allow me to choose a username
anyone on twitter
probably some of you on twitter
twitter allows you to log in using an
email address
or your phone number associated with
your account
or your twitter handle
my twitter handle is my last name tulsan
my email address is something at
toolsam.net i have the i have the domain
obviously pair at hossem.net
but it's
faster for me if i'm going to type it in
it's faster for me to just type in
toolset
now if you allow users to pick a
username not just an email
or they can log in using the phone
number as an example it will be easier
for them to log in
and you could eventually also allow
people to choose
what would you like to use to log in a
username a phone number an email address
or
something else because that could be
sort of a secret
because most people don't consider a
username to be a secret because it's an
email address it's your email address
which is public information mostly
but why can't the username also be a
secret
or at least a semi-secret
so there are pros and cons of using
allowing usernames instead of just email
addresses as usernames
and you need to consider this obviously
in in every single case and then you
also have the password requirements
password requirements can be found
everywhere and it's just again plain
freaking stupid to do
requiring people to use three out of
four character groups uppercase
lowercase
uh numbers and digits and special
characters it's stupid
because we know password crackers like
me we know that if you ask the people to
create a complex password
the first letter will be uppercase the
rest will be lowercase and at the end
you have an exclamation mark
the exclamation mark is being used twice
as much as all the other special
characters on your keyboard in passwords
password exclamation mark
amazing security very predictable
so remove the password complexity
requirements
because length by itself creates
complexity
you can also consider implementing
a client-side password generator because
people are not creative a lot of you
are not creative
so when you ask people hey
create a password and do it now it's
like
one two three four five six exclamation
mark oh that's too short password
exclamation mark that works
so why not suggest
a password or a passphrase this is my
beloved passphrase exclamation mark
because i'm predictable
you could do that
you could suggest two or three or four
random words from a word list
there's a methodology for that called
diceware which is cryptographically
secure
if you pick
three or four random words from a word
list that contains approximately seven
and a half thousand words
you have so many combinations available
that it is impossible to crack it
cryptographically
which is pretty awesome
what you could also do what you should
do is to implement a feature in the
password field where you can choose to
show or hide the password
i had a discussion a couple of years ago
in las vegas with some usability
designers
and they were really proud because they
had implemented this feature and i
looked at the webpage and they had this
open eye saying hey now you can see the
password and closed eye
it you know it's not visible and i said
well have you watched a lot of the rings
or have you
had a look at the
u.s dollar bills
a single eye in certain religions is an
evil eye
like in lord of the rings
so trying to get away don't use
religious symbols is a tip for you try
to avoid that
instead you can implement something as
simple as using the text show and hide
in here to show or
hide the password in the password login
field
and
also this field you know the confirm
your password is basically redundant if
you implement especially the show hide
option
then you don't have to enter the
password once more to confirm and then
you make the create a login process
is certainly faster to do
and last but not least for this screen i
would also really
suggest for you to implement
a password strength meter this is simple
gamification
if you
are being told or shown that your
password right now is red like you enter
one two three four five six
it's red
but if it is this is my beloved
passphrase exclamation mark
period
then you would have a green score and
people want in general they want to be
good they want to do good so if you
implement gamification like this that
actually increases password strength and
password security
with one exception call mccurley at
microsoft research he did a paper on
this he looked into gamification and he
said gamification works haha big
surprise we knew that
but he also found that if you use
gamification
for password strength for a site or
service that doesn't matter to the user
i mean i'm signing up for your online
shoe store for the very first time ever
you want my name and address and phone
number which is public information
anyway and then you ask me to set a
strong password and there's a password
strength method
even then i'm like yeah but it's just a
shoe store and they're just asking me
for name address and phone number so you
know i i don't care about this counters
at all it has no value to me
and that's one of the things you need to
be aware of when you have users or new
customers signing up
initially when they sign up that account
has absolutely zero value to them
so they are most likely to choose a very
simple password they may even enter
wrong information they don't care false
information because they just want to
look around
and you should be aware of that in the
context that at some point when they're
going to do a financial transaction if
they're going to enter a credit card if
going to purchase any anything expensive
or leave any kind of sensory information
that's the point in time where you
should like care for the user and say
okay well now you're going to enter
sensitive information about yourself
personally sensitive information
now
would be would be like a good time to
configure different indication wouldn't
it instead of doing that initially
because then you have lots of people
dropping off on the onboarding process
uh two factorication oh come on man i
just want to have a look at the shoes
so they will just drop out
so your password contains invalid
characters and
from many years ago
because this is the wrong audience to
say this to no your startup contains
incompetent engineers
and it was hangarbell thomas who tweeted
that so it's it's not me saying that
but he's
sort of correct
your password and one's password should
be pos it should be possible to use
pretty much anything even the incredibly
dangerous sql injection characters scott
and
again
learn some basic hygiene learn some
basic
input output controls to learn how to
check if
learn how to handle your password
correctly
basically in your code
and also about the gamification path
this is also important because having a
password strength meter
is good as i said
but it's also important to remember you
can't trust a password meter
because what makes a strong password any
suggestions
what is the strong password
hi
scott it's
we are going to have to talk about this
again no it's not entropy
a strong password is i mean here's a
website how secure is my password
and i have entered my name
per tool same
and the system says
a hacker is going to use
923 000 yes to crack that now
me using my own name
as my password do you think that's a
good choice
is that a strong password
no
if scott is using petrussim as his
password would that be a good choice for
him
it would be better
it's not
incredibly secure
but it's better
that's a very simple way to tell you
that no you should not trust password
meters but again implementing them to
give the user a certain idea if your
password is sort of
strong
it's a very good idea to do
and then also the question of two five
communication
as i said
i'm joining up for your online store and
i want to purchase shoes i couldn't care
less about your company your services or
your shoes at the point in time now
because the account has absolutely zero
value to me i haven't left my credit
card nothing in there
so
do we configure two types of the gauge
in now
or at a later point i already gave away
my answer to that one
you asked the user to configure to
authentication
as soon as they do something which could
be
important to them like a financial
transaction or entering any kind of
sensitive data as an example but you
have to be the judge on when and how to
do this
because again as i said initially use
two-factor authentication everywhere
and how do we do truth amplification
well we use our phone
most of the time
we receive text messages all the time
with otps
we have totp apps microsoft
authenticator google authenticator and
god knows how many
more and people
sometimes forget that people
run out of battery
they don't have coverage in the area or
in the country they're in
they have data turned off because they
don't want to pay for expensive data
packages
they
lose their phone
they smash it
or it gets stolen
something as simple as a company sending
you an otp
by text message and you have probably
seen this a lot of times but i'm pretty
sure most of you have never really
thought about it
the way you do that text message
parts of the text message will be given
a preview on your lock screen in most
phone configurations
so if the otp is the only thing in the
text message you will see it even on a
lock screen on a locked phone it will
show up
but if that text message
starts with hi
here is your otp
line break line break and then you have
the otp code
the otp code by itself would not show up
in the preview of the text message on
screen
very big difference
in some threat scenarios
i do a bit quite a bit of traveling
sitting in an airport lounge have you
ever been to cafe or airport lounge and
see people like leave their phone and
leave their laptop maybe even open
to go to the man's room or ladies room
well they do that and i'm i'm sort of
fine with that when people tweet out
picture pictures on twitter saying like
here's another idiot who just left his
laptop unlocked in the cafe
and his phone as well or her phone
i tweet back back at them saying
then it's really good that you are there
to look after it
that's my response
now i was i and if any of you are doing
this i'm sorry for saying this but i was
an for quite a few years
with my colleagues who forgot to
lock their laptop
when they went away
i've changed
into saying that
if somebody forgot to lock the laptop i
will actually stay beyond even in a cafe
and it's a complete stranger i will stay
behind and just make sure that nobody
runs away with that laptop
i won't go over there and just like you
know windows l to lock it
because it's not my computer i'm not to
touch it i would just look after it for
the owner
and when the owner gets back depending
on the person i would eventually say
you know i i have a
small tiny tip for you don't be that
trustworthy
and by the way i'm a password hacker so
now you learn your lesson
it's that simple
now i do work for for vips in norway i
do work with security for bank id and
here's our login flow
first of all we have an information
screen we're saying hey what what are we
going to do well we're going to confirm
your identity
and number two enter username which for
bank id is your social security
number
and then
here we are you well in my case i'm
using um
an app
so i get a ping in that app on my phone
um
and i say i confirm then it's me that's
basically me entering the otp
and if the otp is correct then i get to
the screen where i need to enter my
password
notice the flow here
because
many services have two-factor indication
pretty much all of them
i have no idea scott have you ever seen
any service apart from bank id in norway
where they ask you for username and then
they ask you for valid otp and if that
otp is correct then they ask you for
your password
no
and i can't understand
why not why did you do it that way
because when they ask for username and
then password it means that any password
hacker can make as many attempts as they
want if you don't have any account
account lockout or
rate limiting on your service they will
have multiple attempts at trying to
guess people's password but if you have
to enter the correct otp first
they will never get to the password
screen where they can actually try to
guess your
password it's a very small but
incredibly important change
of the login flow
i'm not saying this is the correct thing
to do for everyone
but by all means look into if you can
make that small change
so username otp password and also keep
people informed about what you're doing
and and why you're doing it and also
give them information about you know if
for some reason you choose to do
password pl username and password and
eventually also otp on the same screen
and if one of those are wrong don't say
something went wrong try again
don't do that that's not good security
that's stupid security tell them that
the username is wrong or the password is
wrong or the otp is wrong
that is helping the hacker just a little
bit
but it is even more important to give
useful information to your customers
because we need to build trust with our
users
this is
an article that i wrote for a computer
world norway like
13 years ago or something it's norwegian
you can still find it online it's our
official channels
i wrote this because i got annoyed by a
lot of com companies that were sending
me
text messages emails and they even have
had these pop-ups on their uh online
store in i actually wrote this because
of my own bank
i entered my
bank i wanted to do some online banking
obviously and when i enter the home page
of my bank it's like boom here's a
pop-up like would you like to answer a
few questions about our bank
and if you participate you can win some
money
and the pop-up doesn't look like
anything that is designed by the bank
and it's like
hey where this does this pop-up come
from i mean i'm at the bank
but i know this much i
cannot be totally sure that that pop-up
actually comes from my bank
and there's no information i remove the
pop-up and i look at the bank's website
and there's no information that they are
running a marketing survey now
so what do i do well i'm being a what
not a trailer troll but a real world
troll
i call my bank i ask for the director of
of information you know pr department
and i said hi this is pear i'm a really
annoying customer are you
running a marketing survey online on
your website now yes or no
um
[Music]
uh i i need to check and get back to you
yeah because there's a pop-up coming on
your home page and there's no way to
verify for me whether this is actually
coming from the bank or if it is spam or
fraud or
you know i have no idea what
and that person called me back like two
hours yet later and oh yeah it's a
marketing survey oh fine thank you and
now to avoid me calling you again or
anyone else calling you with the same
question
include some freaking information about
your website that in these days starting
this day and on this day we are doing
marketing survey which will show up as a
pop-up on screen or you can click here
to participate
because you know it is
a bit annoying to get that pop-up
because i'm not entering my bank to
answer a marketing survey i'm there to
do online freaking banking
so don't be annoying
oh yeah that's a really good idea
so i wrote this article and a lot of
companies and organizations in norway
they set up a single page on their
website named our official channels or
our channels
where they list all the channels they
use for email for social media like
here's our facebook account here's our
instagram page here's
our tiktok account here's the email
addresses we use to communicate with you
and they are being sent out by these
third-party providers
it's a dead simple web page to do you
don't have to update that page every
week every month
but it creates trust
for people like me at least that are
just a bit paranoid
and of course you could also include the
security.txt file
everybody knows security.txt
raise your hand do you know this one
and for those who don't know it
do it securitytext.org
it's a simple text file where you tell
ethical hackers you tell scott
that he if he finds a vulnerability
here's how to contact us and report that
to us
incredibly simple lots of sites doesn't
do this
and then suddenly we have a situation
where oh i need to change my
password and i go online to your store
again because i want to change my
password
now you see a user coming there and they
want to change your password
wouldn't it be nice to just ask
why are you coming to us to change your
password
nobody does that
but it could be that i want to change my
password because i think somebody had
obtained illegal access to my account
like asking
hey you want to change your password
fine
would you like to warn us about you know
somebody else being aware of your
password has your account been
compromised by anyone or something
that simple question to ask
and in most cases people just change
their password because they want to
change it
and no
people don't do that
people change passwords for reason a
security reason in most cases so why not
ask them why are you changing your
password
and talking about changing passwords
ricky mondello and
forgot a name theresa at apple
they have this one a well-known url for
changing passwords
so you have a web page where people go
to change their password right
and here is a url
at a fixed location and password
managers or anyone else they can go to
that specific url which is known
well known across all websites if you
configure it
and that again that url points to the
page where you change your password
if you may implement this and again this
is
easy to do
then password managers will also have a
much better
and easier job to help you change your
password across many many different
sites and services
why not help password managers and users
to figure out
where do i change my password because if
you go into 10 different sites and say i
want to change my password there are 10
different urls 10 different layouts and
everything to change your password
here's a fixed url that you can
configure then again points to the page
where you change your password
when
apple announced this it was like
yes
i and i've been doing this stuff now for
you know password passwords have been my
interest for more than 23 years now
approximately
and i was like why didn't i think
about that
but this is brilliant
absolutely brilliant and you should do
this
on any and all sites and services that
you are running online that's my opinion
and there's a blog post as well that you
can find on this addressweb.tab slash
change password url that
explains it a little bit more and give
you examples on how to do it if you want
to read a little bit more about it
and you also have cases like you know i
forgot my password
now i want to change my password is
something different than i forgot my
password and you can also have people
reporting in like oh i have i can't
remember my username
or i think my account has been
compromised
do you have any kind of process flow
designed to handle those different cases
because
i forgot my password is
interesting again to ask
well did you forget your password
or could it be that somebody have get or
obtained illegal access to your account
and change your password
so when you think you don't remember it
it's actually someone someone who has
changed your password that could be the
case
so you need to look for indicators of
compromise there's a billion ways to do
that ask scott or ask jim look at to
uvasp not going into the details of that
but it's a good smart thing to do
and something as simple as
well um i see that you are changing your
password or you have forgotten your
password now under the assumption that
you when you say you forgot your
password you go into the password reset
process
should we also there ask you
are you doing this because you think
somebody have gained legal access to
your account
you could ask an example when you change
your password successfully and get gain
access again
should you show the user hey here are
all your
valid session tokens or cookies or
whatever you call them
should you show them you know you are
logged in from these devices from these
browsers and would you like to kill
those sessions
and in what cases would you ask the user
should we clearly kill these sessions
and
under what circumstances should you just
say kill them all because we think or we
know the account is compromised
i don't have the exact answer for you
you have to design this process you have
to do the risk analysis yourself
but it's again something that i very
rarely see options for doing on online
on most sites
so i'm a big fan of us nist and the
standard called sp 800-63b
this is for digital identity guidelines
authentication and life cycle management
it was published in june 2017
if you are having sleeping problems this
is the paper for you to read
but this is brilliant
there's a ton of people
that sort of worked or assisted with
nist
like myself doing conferences doing
talks
discussing up and down to internality
and the output ended up on this standard
which says a lot that you should most
definitely read and read again
some of the highlights from this
standard is saying that well you
shouldn't do false or regular password
change hooray
you should drop the complexity
requirements because simply a long
password makes a strong password
if you use the letter a or the number
one
74 times
that can be sort of considered a really
strong password
because if somebody if i'm supposed to
you know i'm going to hack your account
what will i do
well password one exclamation mark
obviously oh no that's the that
that didn't work okay
uppercase p then or maybe two
exclamation marks
and how many attempts will a hacker try
out against an online form before they
get tired or you hit a rate limiting
or eventually also the account is locked
out
very few
online
hacking
is a very slow process to do
cormac hurley at microsoft research
wrote a paper saying that for the online
online attack scenario it doesn't make
sense to make do more than say a
thousand to maybe ten thousand attempts
when you've done that and you can't get
access
move on to the next account and try to
get in
but for offline brute force hacking of
passwords
that means i have a password hash of
your password
and i use powerful nvidia gpu clusters
to crack your password working at
hundreds of billions of attempts per
second
then it's a completely different ball
game but what people forget all the time
is that if somebody have been able to
gain access to your password hash from
some kind of service
that service is already royally
hacked up and down
and there's actually no point in
cracking your password for that service
because your data is already gone they
have already gained access to your data
tracking your password through offline
brute force tracking using a hashcat and
nvidia gpus
that is something they do
to overrefine
your data so they can try to use your
account information and the password to
gain access to other sites and services
on on the internet as well
but there's
no initially there's no point in
tracking your password like that
and people forget that
so one of the things that i did in my
previous job i was working as the chief
security officer of nordic choice hotels
a large hotel chain in scandinavia
when i started there in 2017 i said well
i want to implement the nist sp
800-63b standard
for passwords
at multi-choice house
and my colleagues they look at me like
yeah
whatever and i talked to the
communications department internally and
i said well there's a few challenges
here
one of the things i did was to implement
the open password filter which you can
find on github i think it's still there
this is
it's a password filter for windows
and again referring back to comic early
if you do block the 1000 to 10 thousand
most popular passwords on the internet
you'll be fine
just don't allow users your customers to
use
the top thousand or ten top ten thousand
passwords don't allow them to use those
because those are too easy to guess
so
we were in a hotel of another choice a
hotel chain in scandal 18 000 employees
six countries 210
locations and 170 different
nationalities working for the hotel
chain at the time
that was
before the pandemic
so i talked to the communications
department and said hey um
i
want to implement the nist standard so
i'm going to remove the complexity
requirements hooray i want to set the
minimum length for passwords to 15.
you're gonna die
so i talked to them i need to
communicate this in a good way
and again very small difference
from now on your password has to be 15
characters
but you don't have to make it complex
[Music]
you never have to change your password
again yes
but it has to be 15 characters long well
that's fine
i've been asking those questions for
people for years and years to end
and just the order of communicating this
is incredibly important
so
would you like to never have to change
your password again is the message we
communicated to the employees technology
choice and to no surprise everybody was
like
i'll do anything
to not have to change my password ever
again well
unless of course we think or we know
that your password has been compromised
then obviously we need to do something
so we sent out a message and the big
header of course was like
now you don't have to change your
password ever again
but we are increasing the minimum length
from 8 characters to 15 characters
and we didn't say anything about
removing the password complexity
requirement that's exact information
it's really not needed to give it out
and i was really curious what's going to
happen now you know what happened next
when we send out this message
absolutely nothing
i didn't even get a hug
nobody responded to that message
and i was like
that's mere
i i i know i'm in security so i know
that some people sort of like don't like
me or like us
but again it was
it was strange to experience
um so some of the things that i do to
explain why did i do this because just
implementing the standard yes but there
needs to be a reason
and one of the things that i did before
implementing this change i talked to
our internal help desk
and i asked them do you you know make a
note of all the that you have yes we
have really good tracking of all issues
being reported to us
well do you also register like you know
i forgot my password
yes we do
so i asked for statistics and if if you
see on the top left corner it says
pierce pavarza paso passage as a swedish
colleague
who who wrote that and i promised him to
leave it on the slide because he he
thought i was a complete nut case which
i sort of am about passwords
so he created statistics for me
and i would i was asking for was
basically how many requests do we have
per day
week month year of the kind that says i
forgot my password
because in a large corporation what
happens
when somebody have forgotten their
password well they make another try or
three attempts or five attempts
and then they
then they just oh it's it's i
forgot it's monday
so i'd grab some coffee i will talk to
some colleagues and then i'll get back
to my computer and we'll make three more
attempts
and after some time they will finally
resign and like i have to call
helpdesk
now the time wasted by that employee
because they are not being productive
when this happens
and then you also have the time needed
by helpdesk to verify is it actually you
or is it somebody trying to pretend to
be you to gain access to your account
i said and this is this is just like
that i said that
it's a one hour there's one hour of lost
productivity to the company for every
single i forgot my password request to
helpdesk
that's the cost one hour
and i saw that i if i could reduce the
number
of forgot password requests by 50
percent
i would be saving the company
16 1500 1600 hours
every year
and that's just saving
time saving money
but that's also a lot more happy
employees
which is also something
positive
so i saw that after changing uh the
password policy uh boring statistics we
saw that the number of lost password
requests dropped rapidly
which was really really good
and i was traveling around in norway and
sweden and denmark and i was talking to
employees in the hotels did you notice
that you haven't changed your password
for like
more than a year now
huh
yeah that's
true is there something wrong no no no
no no no no no no it was actually me
changing the policy
oh thank you it's a lifesaver for me
okay well yeah i'm nice to hear that and
you're welcome
um
do i get a room upgrade now but uh yeah
hi
so a lot of people are sending also out
otps even by email they are sending out
you know verify your email uh click this
link and so on
now email is not secure the norwegian
ncsc
security authority of norwich says that
it's not an email is and remains the
most important initial attack vector in
order to insert malware inside an
organization or network
so the confirm your email site click
here to sign up for our service or
here's your otp or hair seo password
reset link you really need to be aware
those are incredibly effective attack
vectors as well
so i'm not saying you shouldn't be using
email but you really think you need to
think about the process flow of this
one of the things you can do is to look
at the digital sense directorate in
norway
the government they have some standards
that are recommended on how to make
email
at least a little bit more secure and i
know from experience and research that
most
companies in norway they haven't
deployed the standards internet
standards
recommended by norwegian government and
the most funny part of it
the two government organizations
including the hosting staff
that do recommend these
from back in 2018
even they haven't implemented these
standards themselves yet which is
funny i guess
but i'm nagging them all the time to do
it because it's not hard
when you know how to do it
and the super financial authority of
norway also said many years ago that yes
we think that in the future and this is
in 2013 we do expect a lot of people to
get their phones hacked
i
have a girlfriend now for three years uh
i think it was one of the first evenings
she visited me
you know i had turned down the lights
something to eat and drink watching a
romantic movie on netflix
and suddenly her phone says ping
and i'm like yeah you can check that of
course if you like and i just put the
movie on pause
and she starts typing on her phone and
i'm like yeah
fine you know do whatever you need to
and after some time she suddenly says is
it normal that netflix is asking for my
social security number and i'm like okay
lights on tv off romance is dead give me
your phone please
that's the text message
uh if you don't understand norwegian i'm
pretty sure you can uh understand from
what's at the bottom it's like netflix
saying hey there's something wrong with
your account and she was just about to
give away everything uh bank id and otp
password and so on to the bad people
so my phone is my castle
and that's where people have their
secrets these days
and i'm going very quickly through this
but i've been talking before about how
how i can hijack your phone
uh there were some broad press coverage
on that in 2019 in doug and snanks leave
the newspaper
uh which i was sort of behind where we
showed that we could easily hijack your
phone and i also show that for
at least 10 to 13 years
it had been possible to break into and
listen to a manipulative voice mailbox
of approximately six to seven million
people in norway sweden and denmark
using spoofing
and
worse
there was an article in norwegian news
media in 2006 and 2007 that in detail
described how to do it
but the telecom operators in norway
didn't notice so it went unnoticed and
unfixed until i
brought it into media in 2019 and of
course i did it responsibly so they
fixed it before they ended up in the
news
so going quickly through this and i did
a joke on pins and uh yesterday
uh here are these students that are
asked about the pin code but some
interesting statistics some of the most
common four-digit pins
look at them and see if you can i
identify your own one two three four the
quad zero two five eight zero look at
your phone and you will figure out why
two five eight zero is very popular it's
just a line straight down
but five six eight three is the funny
one
5683 does it
bring a bell
anyone here old enough to have been
using t9 on a mobile phone to text many
many years ago
5683 is the english word
love
so you remember love which is something
you want to remember in most cases
and you type in 5683
that's love so one of the most common
pin codes you can find
so i've been doing research into
people's choice in in pink hoes as well
it's uh funny as an example
i asked people to generate four-digit
memorable pink four digit non-memorable
and also seven digit memorable pin codes
in norway
in norway there is absolutely nothing
that we use in our
daily lives that contain seven digits
so when i ask people to generate a seven
digit memorable pink code people like
one two three four five six seven
and it's also funny to see that if you
ask them to create a memorable pin
they will not be using uh the number six
and also four digit non-memorable they
will not be using the number zero it's
basically not it's not random enough
so very few people will be using zero in
the pin code as an example
and you could do crazy statistics on
this you can generate heat maps
showing you that
these are the two first digits of the
pin
and these are the two last digits of the
so you have pin code starting with 19
and going up here
it's a strong blue line so it's
year of
birth and this more or less blocked down
here is basically
birth dates
day and month
and the line that goes up here
that's zero zero zero zero going all the
way up to nine nine nine nine so as an
example five five five five is a very
popular pin code
can you code something for me online
where people can enter a pin code and
generate a heat map like that i'm
willing to
ship you a dollar or two for doing that
it's a very
uh i think it is a simple thing to do
now the fun thing is in the research
world
we can essentially say that if i can
steal
11 credit cards by the end of the day in
here
the only thing i know is that you have
chosen the four digit pin code yourself
i don't know gender age or origin or
anything about you
but i do know
use the chosen pin and i know that i
have three attempts before the card stop
working
11 cards statistically i will be able to
guess the correct pin code on one in 11
cards
awesome statistics if you're working in
a pub
so creating a non-memorable pin
again
the norwegian name johansson translates
into five six four two six seven three
six
and you don't have to remember the pin
you just remember the name johansson
so some of us are dreaming of fido and
web offense
if you haven't if you don't know about
this you really should look into it
i'm dreaming of offing
about it as well and it looks like
something like this a ub key or other
devices that may have or may not have a
fingerprint reader as an example
and webbing fan is fantastic it's
proven you know you can't phish
anyone using web both and authentication
but there are problems with it at nordic
choice uh
hotels here's one of the hotels uh where
i do visit frequently this is the
reception a reception area and they have
these nice big really good looking
computers standing on the desk and
here's the payment terminal and the
final problem is that the usb ports are
only on the back of the screen so they
are facing
you
the customer the user
the bad guys
now if you do insert the ubikey in there
what do you think might happen
somebody will just ah i'll tag that
please and suddenly they will not be
able to log in
and also from a usability perspective
they stand in front of the screen to log
in but then they have to reach back to
go behind the reception to click on the
button to be able to log in very simple
usability stuff but again in some cases
cases it's just hard to implement
so i will end this by
telling you
why you should write down your passwords
and i will do that it's a video it's a
one minute long i made this many many
years ago and i will do the voice over
because the original is in norwegian
so here we go why you should write down
your passwords
to our young ones
dear mom and dad
if you are reading this letter i have
probably gone missing against my own
will
in this letter i have written down
usernames and passwords for the sites
and services that i use for my phone
email
facebook instagram snapchat tick tock
and so on
this is information that you and the
police
may need to in order to be able to find
me
please remember that i love you
and she inserts that into an envelope
and then
on the outside of that envelope it says
for emergency purposes only
because electronic traces are being more
and more important for
people for the police to find you to
find us
if we go missing
and this is a reality which is happening
unfortunately
way too often
and that's why you should write down
your password and that's why you should
recommend your family and friends to do
so as well
put it in the envelope that sets for
emergency purposes only
and give that envelope to somebody you
trust
thank you
slightly over time but i will stick
around for
at least 30 minutes so if you have
questions or comments
feel free
take a figure okay
questions
again i said eight hours i i'm pretty
sure you believe me now i can actually
go on for eight hours
but this was a very ultra brief
introduction to the topic and there's so
much more i could have talked about yes
you recommend that you do otp before you
do passwords
i feel like that is
it's convenient for bank id because you
know that everyone has
an otp
does it still work for services where
otps are
you know or otps are
optional
well there's one attack that you can do
against this i'm the kind of guy who
thinks like an attacker most of the time
so
just recently there have been articles
i'm not sure if there's academic
research but there has been articles out
in the press saying that
if there's a login form where i enter a
username and then otp but the otp will
be totp and you're using microsoft
authenticator or google authenticator
then i can just hit that again and again
and again and again again
and if you are using an online app where
you get a notification like microsoft
authenticator would you like to is it
you trying to log in
if i just hit that many many many times
in the end because your phone will go
bing bing bing bing bing bing do you
want to allow access or not
it has been shown that a lot of people
are just getting annoyed and they think
i've said no no no no no no no and it
doesn't go away okay yes
and then the attacker gets in
so that's one of the many risks that you
have to consider in this
so
i said that it could be a good flow to
do i'm not saying it's the best way to
do it in all circumstances no
more questions yep what's your
recommendation when a company has
clients who hold on to the obsolete
password requirements like
complexity
rotation
i'm i'm
i have a full-time job
i don't do consulting i'm not allowed to
do consulting but i am allowed to do
free talks
so um
set up a
seminar for your customers and invite me
and maybe i can convince them
that's
that's what i usually say
you know calling them idiots is not
going to work but uh yeah
more questions
okay once again thank you i'll be around
a little more